- Like, there are people who literally
think this glass is empty.
(laughs)
There are literally people who think it.
You know?
And I just genuinely, and I'm not kidding,
sorry I'm taking your water.
(laughs)
I'm gonna run out of room
and I don't care about this carpet.
This shit right here?
This is full as fuck for me.
Full as fuck.
You give me that, I know
exactly what to do with it.
I know exactly what to
do with what's in there.
And that's it.
That's my fuckin' life right there
in a cup full of,
that's it.
I know exactly what the
fuck to do with this,
and other people don't know what to do
with a full fuckin' container.
There's something very
powerful about consistency.
I eat my own dog food.
I think the thing that
makes me sleep at night
like a baby is everything
I tell you do, I do.
I don't even know how many followers,
how many subscribers I have on YouTube.
I subconsciously know,
and theoretically know
that I'm not growing on views on YouTube
and weirdly, I love that
because I think I'm doing this
exchange program
of people who watch like
four months of DailyVee,
and they'll be like,
okay, fuck it, let's go.
It's so crazy when you say the same thing
84 thousand different ways.
You never know when the person
on the other side's ready,
and you said it that right way,
and that became it.
- [Female] That's exactly
what happened to me,
I had to hear it so many times,
until I really realized
what you are saying.
Because a lot of people
have said the same thing
that you said but it had to be someone
I can relate to.
And someone that I really think,
okay, he knows his shit.
He should know.
- To me what's interesting,
thank you, the other thing that's gonna be
super interesting is when
voice becomes real real.
I'm so deep, so heavy,
I have a funny feeling, like,
a lot of people hear me on social
and are going and it's working,
and in like 26 months when they plateau or
they've had success,
plateau comes not like,
you stopped growing.
Plateau sometimes is,
you don't love it as much.
You don't feel on fire.
It'll be interesting,
I'm really fascinated to watch
what happens, the level,
I've been really thinking a lot lately
for the first time of like,
oh shit, five years from
now is gonna be really cool.
Level of recalling content,
like I'm really into,
we're not doing a good job with this
but we're doing the team
in a way that I think will.
There's so much Throwback Thursday
content that I should be putting out.
It's just so interesting
to watch something
from 2012.
I love when I do that stuff,
but we're not really going hard yet.
- It's also great to see
it's the same messages over and over,
but then that there's
that evolving over time.
And the story is like amazing.
People, when I'm telling them about you
it's like, oh it's the same message
and I'm like, yeah but you gotta
really pay attention.
There's
- [Female] Nuances.
- Every,
and then the most important part is,
I don't think what people realize is,
especially if they want
something for themselves,
it's not about the content,
it's about me executing the
awareness of the content.
It's meta.
Once you get it down,
the reason I think I have longevity is
cool, you've got it down,
you're in the same wavelength, cool.
By the way, which is rare.
People are like,
anybody who says, oh, it's the same stuff
is actually not in the zone.
They're looking for an excuse.
It's the same stuff,
aka I'm not gonna let
you get away with it.
- [Female] Yeah.
- Which is why most people don't want to
actually stick with me, or like it.
They want the excuse.
- [Female] They want someone to tell 'em,
oh, it's okay.
- 100 thousand percent,
or, or what's the saddest part is
they want the bullshit version of me
which is,
I'm gonna make you pay me
to make you feel that way
and because you're paying me
900 dollars a month,
you think you're doing something.
- That's motivation for some people too.
(laughs)
- Well, on the other side,
but I'm talking about the person.
The person that's consuming it,
the reason it's, oh it's the same thing
is they want the excuses
and they want somebody
to say it's okay,
but there's a scarier one to me.
That's okay, that's like
that one's kind of like,
you're compassionate
but not thoughtful contemporary.
Right?
Or, it's not okay, let me phrase.
It's one of two people
that gives you room to be it's okay.
They love you blindly.
Your mom, if you're lucky enough.
Your sister, brother, whatever.
Somebody who loves you
and thinks they're doing the right thing.
Or, somebody who loves
you or doesn't love you
that just likes misery loves company.
Like, the worst thing
would be for you to shine.
And not that they hate you,
it's just they hate themselves.
And if you go and win,
that sucks.
So then they're like, no no it's okay,
because stick with me, let's
watch the rodeo tonight
and do nothing.
Right?
North Dakota.
(laughs)
- [Female] Let's watch the snow melt.
- But, but, the
the scarier version of that to me,
is the bullshit version of me.
When I watch people
comment and they're like,
oh I get more value from X.
I'm like, fuck.
They're in such a bad place because they
are paying somebody to make them
think they're doing something.
That one's scary.
I like fun.
Something I'm trying
to figure out more of,
fun is interesting.
Bartering is fun.
Contests are fun.
Raffles are fun.
It's a fun way to get
the community involved.
This content is good.
I think about all the
people that didn't win,
but now are gonna watch this video,
who bought 10.
Who, this video, 'cause
of the serendipity,
it's all so meta,
so much more meta than people realize.
I bought 10.
I bought 10 because I really wanted to
be one of you four people, right?
I lost.
I'm a little mad.
I'm sad, I overextended myself.
What the fuck am I gonna do with,
this is real people,
what am I gonna do with
10 fuckin' books now?
Right?
But listen, when you're easier for people
in places of income
where they can afford it,
there's some people,
and I always get scared of people
overstretching themselves
for a lot of
here's the psyche.
It's the same people that are
paying those other people.
I'm gonna win, this is it,
it's my time.
I'm convinced, it's the
fuckin' secret out here.
I'm gonna buy the 10 books,
I can't afford the 180 dollars
that these 10 books, but I'm gonna win.
I'm gonna fly to New York,
Gary's gonna give me
the fuckin' Midas Touch.
(group reacts)
And then they, the raffle happens
and they lose.
That's devastating to me.
What's exciting to me though is,
they lose, this video's
gonna be put on YouTube,
Facebook, LinkedIn,
they're gonna watch it.
And something in your question
makes them willing to promote now
and not be scared about it,
and the 17th time they do
it was the thing that led to the
same thing they were trying to do and get
by the Midas Touch in this meeting.
It's how it works, for real.
Interesting, right?
- [Male] Awesome, yeah.
- People are just not,
you know what?
It's the way I think about
branding and internet marketing.
Internet marketing, aka last touch,
attribution, quant-based,
math-based selling,
people aren't being thoughtful.
They don't think Facebook
works as good as Google,
because a Facebook ad
costs them 88 dollars
to get a coat sold, and Google's 72.
What they don't realize
is Google does no branding
and every picture and video did branding
for you on Facebook.
To live that long,
he's 21 years old.
It took another 10 years
before I even made my
first video online.
He's got 10 more years of living.
- Super inspiring by the way.
- Right, you're 32.
I was 31 years old.
I was 30 actually, it was February 26th.
But, it was, you know what I mean?
But 32,
I was two years into Wine Library TV
and nobody gave a fuck, fuck, fuck.
And to be very frank,
at the level that we're
even talking about,
nobody gave a fuck 18 months ago.
Some people gave a fuck.
Now it's, everyone's gonna
eventually give a fuck.
But, yeah.
- [Female] Since I'm in New York,
I brought this bag where
I printed your quote,
it's one that I really live by.
I really don't complain at all for nothing
and never at all.
Especially because of my dad's life
and my mom's life and I
- Well that's mine too.
- [Female] Yeah.
- That's, we're so lucky
about the mom and dad's life.
- [Female] Absolutely.
- My mom
grew up in Soviet Russia,
lost her mother at five years old,
her dad went to jail for 10
years when she was eight.
Like,
she came to America with nothing,
she raised three kids by herself,
not one housekeeper for one day ever.
Went on one family vacation,
never bought anything,
and never complained.
So, I'm struggling.
I'm struggling,
I'm struggling.
- [Female] When I hear people complain,
I really get mad.
Like I get furious.
- I get empathetic.
I get empathetic, I do.
I don't get mad, I'm telling you,
I get empathetic.
I realize they don't have perspective.
If you have perspective,
I just almost wish every day
that people could
You know what I would love
virtual reality to do?
There would be an app,
I would build an app
called Your Family Died.
That would be my app.
You go into VR,
you'd walk in, it would feel real.
And you'd watch your family
go into a car accident
and you'd see their fucking death.
Right?
And then you take it out,
and then you live your life,
I promise you, you'll be happy as fuck.
- Brings it back to
your Tony Robbins video.
(laughs)
- [Female] And that's so
funny, the first time I
- Yeah, right?
He said he was,
that was an interesting moment, right?
- Super interesting, yeah.
- We were very different on that.
What was he, he was like,
he does something in the morning?
I don't remember.
- Affirmation's the mirror
- Yeah yeah yeah.
And I'm like, I just make
pretend my mom's dead.
He was like,
he was like
(laughs)
But it's perspective!
- [Female] That's the
crazy thing, I do that too.
I do that because
we flew from war, so for
me it was very natural
- Real war.
- [Female] Yeah.
- You guys know people who died.
I saw people dying on the streets,
they were droven over with trucks,
the big tanks.
- Tanks.
- [Female] I saw that.
- You can't unsee that.
- [Female] No, never.
I was four, but I still remember.
- Of course!
- [Female] I don't have food, I don't have
fuck that!
My parents are healthy,
my family's healthy.
- The end.
Period.
- [Female] The thing
that keeps me still going
and being so humble,
even though at 24 I make
more money than my Dad
does in 10 years.
- 100 percent.
- [Female] It's just
- I genuinely think I'm going to be
one of the most famous,
impactful people ever.
And I feel like I'm
gonna feel the same way
I feel right now.
Which is like, eh okay.
Cool, like, what?
Yes.
Great, I'm excited.
But I don't know,
it's just so obvious to me
that people that have
perspective and don't.
You know?
And then I'll die,
and for 48 hours, on whatever
the way we communicate
as humans, I'll get a ton of love,
you'll all tell your stories,
and then everybody will move on.
And so,
that's how I feel.
If that's what happened to Prince,
if that's what happened to Maya Angelou,
if that's what happens to
that's what's gonna happen
what?
So,
that's it.
- I had the opposite experience,
a spoiled little brat.
And then, started smoking weed at 15 or 16
and my dad just said,
I'm not giving you shit.
Took away everything except
for the roof pretty much.
And just started
- Was that good?
- It was a bad relationship.
- In hindsight are you
happy that happened?
- But I'm happy, 'cause I
had no interests as a teen.
- Of course.
- And then everything started opening up.
It's like,
yeah.
- Honestly bro, I swear to God,
and I really want this for you,
- It kind of, it was like,
either I give you stuff, or the weed
and I'm like, I would prefer to be myself.
And I went that path.
And that was interesting.
Go ahead.
- Just putting pressure on the system.
However he contextualized it,
these are all the things.
You know what's funny?
I just, I said this once before,
I used to say this, I
don't say it much now.
I just think, there's not a lot left here
but like,
there are people who literally
think this glass is empty.
(laughs)
There are literally people who think it.
You know?
And I just genuinely and I'm not kidding.
Sorry I'm taking your water.
(laughs)
Gonna run out of room and
I don't even care about this carpet.
This shit right here,
this is full as fuck for me.
Full as fuck.
You give me that,
I know exactly what to do with it.
I know exactly what to do what's in there.
And that's it,
that's my fuckin' life right there
in a cup form.
That's it.
I know exactly what the
fuck to do with this.
And other people don't know what to do
with a full fuckin' container.
You can't lose by pushing
against your parents
if you follow your heart
because A, if you're successful,
you're a fuckin' Messiah.
And if you're not,
later, later, later,
when they're really old,
they're gonna look you dead in the face,
hopefully nobody dies and everything,
you get this moment,
they'll be proud of you for going for it.
Your mom will secretly say,
hey, by the way, remember 28 years ago
when you went for it?
And we were mad at you?
I'm proud of you, 'cause
I didn't go for it.
And my mom once told me that
she didn't go for it either,
your Grandma, you know what I mean?
- [Female] You can mix and match,
meaning it's
so reckon and fox, whatever
so it's expensive and luxurious.
And what I'm struggling with is that
I hear from a lot of people,
oh, you should go on Amazon and
eBay and whatever.
But because it's such a luxury product,
I'm afraid of putting
that on Amazon and Ebay
- Don't.
- [Female] Changing the experience?
- The experience is one thing.
I was worried that you were worried about
putting it there for brand perception
that those platforms would cheapen it.
Good, that's what I think
you're actually saying.
Because the experience is
you're fucking shipping it.
- [Female] Yeah.
- DHL is DHL or UPS is UPS
or whatever's shipping it, right?
I don't think that's what
you're actually talking about,
you're talking about
- [Female] No no, I mean
absolutely the cheap part, yes.
- It's not an issue.
- [Female] Okay.
If you say it's fine.
(laughs)
- Let me break it down for you
so it's not just blindly
just listen to me.
If somebody of high net worth,
look, if somebody's
buying fox fur or raccoon
or whatever you're, how much is it?
- [Female] Starting
from 300 up to 600 euro.
- Yeah.
I mean, eBay and Amazon are selling
way more luxurious,
and luxurious items, it will
not cheapen your brand at all.
And I do think it will
give your more exposure
and more sales.
- [Females] Yeah it does, absolutely.
- Now, you're gonna make less margin
than you selling it direct,
but I do think it expands your brand,
and I think that's a trade.
I do a lot of
I, for example,
I get paid 150 thousand
dollars to give a speech.
Right?
Ridiculous, it's amazing, thank you.
(knocks)
I'm so blessed.
But I'll give a speech for free.
If I get an email right now that says,
hey Gary, we're the High
School Association of America.
And we're doing this first thing ever.
We got a government grant and
we're bringing one million students
to Central Park.
One million!
Forget Central Park.
Portland.
Some fuckin' park in Portland,
I don't even want to make
it convenient for me.
In Portland, a million
high school students
and we want you to give the keynote.
I'll walk!
'Cause it's a million people, it's brand!
People get fancy when
they start making money.
Yes I get 150, and I turn down
150 to speak all the time.
Yes I will do it for free.
So when I talk about
doing things for free,
people get mad, I've done
stuff for free my whole life
because it's not free, the attent-
I say it all
this is back to how I desperately
am trying to figure out what
you guys are talking about
which is, how do I help more people
actually understand how to get
the most value out of me?
Getting the most
that's how I came up with
don't listen to what I'm saying,
watch what I'm doing.
That is why I think everybody
should watch me forever.
They should do what I do to you.
I don't watch your content.
I watch how you consume content.
I know things about my audience
not based on what they're posting.
I may know more about your habits,
some of these handles,
pants47 or, you know?
I may know more about their habits
or what they're reacting to
and not even know they have two children
even though every post on their
Instagram is two children.
So, I watch what people react to.
I think that's how people should watch me.
I think people should
watch why I do things.
How I do them, and then do them.
If I start a podcast, you start a podcast.
If I start doing more LinkedIn,
you start doing more LinkedIn.
If I put a filter on my
face while I'm doing an
Instagram Live like I just did,
you do that.
There's, that is the game.
Reverse engineer, me
yes, listen to me if you need
the motivation or the insight
or you have a business question, fine.
And I'm flattered and I love it.
But watch
why do I use an example like rodeo
when somebody in the room just spent time
in North Dakota?
Why do I say hockey in Canada,
and football in the U.S.
And proper soccer?
That's me communicating within context.
Got it?
Watch what I'm doing.
By pushing against your parents
if you follow your heart
because A, if you're successful,
you're a fuckin' Messiah,
And if you're not,
later, later, later,
when they're really old,
they're gonna look you dead in the face,
hopefully nobody dies and everything,
you get this moment,
they'll be proud of you for going for it.
Your mom will secretly say,
hey, by the way, remember 28 years ago
when you went for it?
And we were mad at you?
I'm proud of you, 'cause
I didn't go for it.
And my mom once told me that
she didn't go for it either,
your Grandma, you know what I mean?
Being asked is the
ultimate leverage in life.
- Okay.
- You know, to me,
to me, there are ton of people
who booed me along the way,
who didn't want to see me succeed,
this and that.
There's a great story,
I wish Brandon was here
from Wine Library.
There's a great story of a wine supplier
who shit on me so heavy,
and did such the wrong thing,
such the wrong thing.
Did the wrong thing by my business,
I said this once before.
Did something once,
something terrible to me.
Did the wrong thing by Wine Library,
undermined me as a human
being with straight lies.
I went to an event in New York City
where I went to go taste his wine
and he fuckin' said, "get
the fuck out of here,
"you're a piece of shit.
"You're the worst thing
with the wine business."
And then when Wine Library TV blew up,
he sent me an email,
acted as if none of that had ever happened
and asked to be on the show
for exposure for his brand,
and I said "yes".
- Wow.
Why?
- Because being the bigger
person's always right.
Dude, negative,
he knew.
And I know.
As long as everyone knows the score
then you don't need to impose it.
Holding that negativity is stopping you
from what you actually want to happen.
- Okay.
Right on.
- You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- There's a level of being motivated,
and I like that, but fake motivated.
To me, sports is fake.
When I'm working, this is all
if I want to put GQ out of business
with my new ONE37pm,
it's kinda fake.
I wanna put GQ out of business!
But I don't want anything
bad to happen to humans.
And I say, okay, those GQ people will
go work somewhere else,
maybe at ONE37, you know?
So I think you need to be thoughtful
about friends and family
in a different way,
you have to create a
separate space for them.
Because they deserve it.
No matter what, there is
a counter argument to,
when you were four, they fed you.
- Right.
Of course.
(laughs)
- [Female] Always my argument.
- You know?
- Yeah absolutely.
- I think you need to reconcile and
I think the other biggest
piece of advice I'll give you
is somebody who's dealt with
a lot of inner family dynamics,
been in business with my family.
There's always stuff.
You need to let poison out of your body.
If there's things,
you did something and
I caught and I did it
and I do it.
The way I reconcile things
that are frustrating me with
the people I love the most
is by razzing and being snarky
and drilling them.
I do it with my own team.
In a fun kind of, you know?
- Okay.
- Anybody who's like my
parents or my children
there's an undertone.
I get it, I do get it.
- Right.
- I really get it.
- Totally.
- I think you need to let it out.
It's been the best thing I ever did.
My relationships with
everybody in my family
and my team have been exponentially better
as I have in the last half decade
become a much better communicator.
- Okay.
I noticed.
- Got it?
- Yeah.
- Cool.
- [Female] Silly question to start with.
- It's alright.
- [Female] So what if,
okay, I love what I do, right?
Working with athletes and coaching.
- Yes.
- And I'm a runner myself and
where do you cross the line of
I'm not good at,
you want to promote yourself
but you don't want to brag.
Does that make sense?
- Of course!
- Of being able to self promote but not
be all, look at me.
Like, where do you find that line,
I guess it's just a personal decision
of where you find that authenticity?
- That's exactly right.
People have a different point of view on
promotion, self promotion, bragging,
charlatan
- Ego
- Ego, you know,
everybody's got, look,
I mean, the video camera
- I know, wrong, wrong
- No, but I mean it's a
really important point.
I no question sat for a good week
and was like, oof.
Really?
I'm gonna really let somebody follow me?
What does that look like in real life?
I mean this is three years ago now.
- That's a really cool
but I don't want to talk about them
because I feel like it's bragging.
But yet it's my experience.
- Here's what I would say,
couple things.
I never think the truth is bragging.
- That's a great point.
- I just, it's very hard
for me to understand
how the truth is bragging.
- That's a good point.
- You know?
It's just the truth.
Now, let me tell you another way.
You want to go a different way?
So, I got a great idea for you.
And it works for me at times,
sometimes I want to say
things in a different way.
Maybe what you do instead of bragging is
you hit up hundreds of
running and strength
and health and wellness podcasts,
little ones, and ask
them to interview you.
Maybe the way,
that's right.
Maybe being interviewed is easier than,
right?
That's what a lot of people do.
A lot of people just get interviewed.
I love when people are like,
Gary you're such a self promoter,
I'm like, dick, you're on
the fuckin' interview circuit
like crazy.
You're doing the same thing,
you're just disguising it.
- Yeah.
That's a good one.
- You know?
- Yeah.
- So, I would think about that.
- Okay.
Thank you.
- You're welcome.
We'll keep going around.
For awhile, keep going.
Alright, brother.
- I don't have any crazy question,
I'm sure something's gonna come up.
One thing I wanna say
is just like thank you.
I had all my friends saying,
what are you gonna ask,
what are you gonna ask?
What do you want, what do you want?
And I'm like, I don't really want.
Whatever I can do to give back, dude.
- So, I appreciate it.
So what do you think is going on?
I mean you're so early in the journey.
What do you want to do?
Do you want to build a production company?
Do you want to make
content and make a living
of just being a solo creator?
How do you think about it today?
- Today, like right now, I think of it
the way I see myself in long term,
I want to learn how to run a big company.
I love business more than anything.
Growing up with my dad,
my dad's business, answering
the phone at 12 years old,
that kind of thing.
Like you say, eat shit,
forget about everything 'til you're 29.
I'll do that.
- That resonated.
- I mean, I'll do that forever.
- You like the process.
- Yeah yeah, 100 percent.
- I mean, look,
I think at 21 I understood
that it seems like
you had that as well.
That is something I'm
gonna have to go deeper on.
It is actually the ultimate.
I don't know, it's the ultimate.
And I see it in every shape and size.
From crazy hedge fund gal
who makes 88 trillion a year
and she just loves that game
and it's about the money
and it's the point,
mazel tov, good for her!
She just loves the accumulation of wealth
as a hedge fund runner,
to $39 thousand dollar a year
works in a corporation,
loves that stability
of nine to five, loves
three weeks vacation,
loves half-day Fridays in the summer,
loves being the coach of both sons'
soccer and softball teams,
loves doing a very tedious job.
Loves it!
Loves.
It's the fuck, there's
nothing more important than
loving the process.
- Yeah.
- There's just nothing else!
Everything, the reason so many people
are making money online now,
is because there's a
way to love the process
of your process and make money
because the internet
created that infrastructure.
In the same way that
Blockchain will create
peer to peer transactions
that keep the transactions
of money to people,
that's what technologies do.
They change everything.
There used to not be planes, guys.
I don't understand how
people don't understand this.
You weren't born in America,
nobody knew anything about Asia
in this country until like 30 years ago!
You know?
Like, there was no
sushi in fuckin' America
25, 30 years ago.
So, anyway, nonetheless,
that's great, bro.
Like, honestly.
It's funny, I'm going
through the same thing, guys.
I don't think people understand why
the sneaker thing is happening
or the stuff that I'm about to do
over the next three, four years.
I love selling stuff.
It's fun.
The idea of buying something
I love selling, but I
love selling actual stuff
more than I like selling,
I don't like selling
VaynerMedia's services.
I do not get a high,
I had a great meeting yesterday.
We're probably gonna make,
I probably sold something yesterday for
seven million dollars.
Like, in fee.
I'll staff it, we'll have five against it,
I'll make two million dollars profit.
Not fun.
When we do a one-off t-shirt
on my Instagram swipe up,
like you know,
I always wonder if people understand me.
That's the high,
hey, we sold three thousand dollars
worth of t-shirts!
I'm like, yeah!
(laughs)
57 people have that t-shirt, that's cool!
- Do you feel that because you feel like
your brand's getting out there?
- No.
With 57 people?
One Instagram post?
No.
First,
- Why?
- First there's a couple things.
First, it's so humbling that
in the same way that I want
to wear a Macho Man t-shirt,
it's cool to be
this human.
It's just interesting.
It's cool that your
friends think this is cool.
Back to not getting too high,
all the nice things you
guys said, it's funny that
two comments in a row,
this happens all the time to me.
Literally, two comments in a row,
in an Instagram or a YouTube post,
"Jesus Christ, Gary, you're like Jesus."
(laughs)
Right?
Next post.
"This guy is so full of
shit, he's saying nothing.
"Nothing ever."
(laughs)
Right behind each other.
They both grow through me the same way.
(laughs)
We could go to my last post,
I guarantee they're both in there.
Doesn't,
I just don't hear it.
I don't hear it, I don't hear it,
'cause I'm in my process.
So, back to my answer,
no, I think my crescendo,
like my most calm
'cause I'm an operator too.
When I hear 'big company',
where I get scared is I'm like,
I hope that kid understands
the skill set it takes to be an operator.
Not a creator, not a seller,
an operator
is very different.
Which I was blessed with as well.
And there's no question the underestimated
part of my career.
I don't think people
understand what I actually do.
understand the magnitude of
building from scratch, zero,
a billion dollar revenue business
around services.
Not an app.
Right?
Services, this is fuckin' intense.
Do you know how many,
this business does $150 million
with 800 people.
You know how many
businesses do $700 million
with 43?
This is not a good business, this is hard.
But that's okay, I know why I'm doing it.
And I'm doing it because
when I buy a wine brand
or a sneaker brand,
when I buy K-Swiss,
and 52 percent of the people here
now are K-Swiss,
and K-Swiss actually
becomes Nike or Adidas,
that's why I'm doing it.
I think it's strategy.
I think personal development done right
is actually strategy.
Being optimistic is actually just,
it's actually why I'm poking a little,
I want to get some
To me, when somebody's winning,
quantifying anything that's a negative
is so important,
because you want to put
them in the right shelves.
- [Male] Okay.
Yeah.
- What are the right ones?
You know?
- Yeah.
- I still, I know
there's a big difference
of remembering everything,
you know, versus contextual.
For my father, it's hard,
he doesn't get over things.
I watch it.
And I can sense it.
You know?
You have to,
'cause you have so much more upside then.
So, I think the
I think my thing is I run hot and cold,
I run high and low.
I pull from opposite directions.
What I like about you
is I think you understand mentality
but then you also do.
When I hear personal
development and motivation
I get scared because I see a world,
whenever I do a keynote with Tony Robbins,
I'm doing some events,
I genuinely believe that audience
skews towards not doing.
I genuinely do,
I think they go to that
conference to get motivated,
check the box,
a version of paying somebody
to being their mastermind.
I'm doing something.
No you're not!
And I genuinely think that that's why
I'm a lightning bolt in a lot of ways
as a personal,
and it comes from
people have very different and
passionate reactions to me,
because I'm doing something
fundamentally different.
I really am.
I believe in that mentality, strategy.
But fuck, man,
you better work.
- [Female] Absolutely.
- If you want.
You don't have to work.
You have to know yourself,
but nobody's building a
million dollar business
on some trick
or shortcut.
(laughs)
- [Male] It's crazy how much just comes
when you put yourself out there.
The doors open up.
- It's always about execution,
it's my same thesis on names.
When people are like,
what should the name of my thing be?
I'm always like, it won't
matter if you can execute.
- [Male] Faking it 'til you make it,
I, back in University, I picked up
Illustrator, I was never
doing the homework,
I was just doing skills on the side,
learning Adobe.
And, basically,
New York went on strike,
the school I was going to
for three months, and I decided
I wasn't going back, I dropped out.
And I got, I basically had been using
Adobe Illustrator for six weeks
and I went to a job interview.
(laughs)
Everything they said, I was just like,
yeah I can do that, I
can do that, no problem.
Wrote it all down
- To me, to me, to me, brother,
that's a little bit different than
somebody going on
- That was my fake it 'til you make it.
- Yeah.
I'll tell you what fake
it 'til make it is.
A kid rents a tuxedo, rents
goes to his Uncle's best friend's house,
rents a Lamborghini,
drives it to that house,
pays some Instagram models to come
and be in bikinis and then say,
"this is my life, and you can do this too
"if you pay me $6,000
dollars to teach you how."
And there's a lot of that!
Or, borrowing
I've literally had people say,
Gary V, you can help me,
I read a lot of shit.
"Gary V, you can really
help me, I need your help."
And then next line says,
"if you lend me $10 thousand dollars,
"I'll give it right back to you."
And so once in a while,
I'll play a little bit
and be like, "for what?"
They're like, "I know you hate it,
"but I'd love to take a picture with it."
- [Male] Anonymity?
- That's weird you said that.
I actually, randomly, for
the first time in five years
or eight years
had a random thought of,
whoa, what would it be like
(laughs)
Oh, actually it was two nights ago,
my friend Lou was like, I went to Vegas
and did this thing.
It was just something
about the way he said it
and I'm like, and nobody knew who he was.
It was funny, it was the first,
so funny you asked that.
First of all, nobody's ever
asked me that question.
And I've never thought about it.
This is what I believe,
everything's in the air.
Obviously in some weird way,
it's not that I miss it.
Everything has a price.
And if you aspire
(laughs)
if crazy, ambitious and
wonderful thoughts of
Maya Angelou and Gandhi
run through your head,
you're gonna have to realize, cool,
that also means that
there's going to be
not many times ever again
that I will not be known,
and that is weird.
Because I almost can't remember it
at this point, and it's
only been 18 months
where I now know if I'm out,
I will be recognized.
Only 18 months, even though
I've been around for a decade.
Only 18 months,
where I know for fact,
it's impossible for me to go somewhere
and not have somebody know who I am.
Now, that's because
mainly I'm in New York.
It's also where,
if I went to North Dakota
- [Female] Well,
- No, no I know there's people there but
(laughs)
in reality
- [Female] When I went
there to expand my team,
I look for
I found them there,
I speak their language that's perfect.
So I went there and I told them about you
and I brought the books
and I gave them away
and everybody knew you.
It's East Europe
- Yeah.
No I know, it's even in North Dakota and
- [Male] Random people,
I was in the gym this morning at 6 o'clock
and I'm like taking a shower
and getting ready to come here.
And the guy is just like,
he's getting shaving cream or something,
like stupid, right?
And he's like, I don't
wanna get in your way.
And I'm like, ah that's cool and
I just decided to ask him how he's doing.
And we're just literally
in the locker room, right?
And, I'm like, oh yeah
I'm meeting this one dude,
in New York.
Gary?
He's like, you know who?
(laughs)
- [Female] That's the
first thing he thought of?
- Wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute.
No no no no.
You said I'm meeting a random dude
to a random dude in a gym,
and his first thing was
you're meeting Gary?
- [Male] No I said
- Oh okay.
- [Male] I said I'm meeting
this guy who owns an ad agency.
And he's like, "oh, you're meeting Gary?"
- Well that's not bad.
(laughs)
It's happened.
So, the answer is no.
But, I'm aware that it's
never gonna be like it was.
And I lived,
unlike,
I think it's unusual,
it's not unusual, what's
the right way to put it?
30, 40 is not the most common
you start having
Fame comes for athletes and actors,
entrepreneurs now becoming famous
is also
20's and you're really
passionate about something.
If you really want to do something,
you should absolutely do it for free
as long as you can humanly do it.
And in your 20's you're more likely to
be okay with living with your folks,
be okay with getting
together with six buddies
and living in a shithole.
Not eating caviar.
(laughs)
- As long as I had enough
to do the next month,
next month of rent, eating for that month,
I was cruisin'.
- And that's why I razz products a lot.
Even though I sell
sneakers, I don't expect it.
I don't want people to
buy watches or supremes
or even my sneakers if
they can't afford it.
You know?
If it's coming at the expense of them
investing in themselves.
Go ahead.
We'll keep going around
and around and around.
- When you get where you want to go,
and you have hard choices to make,
the things that motivate me,
motivated me before
kind of don't motivate me now.
- Of course.
- Is this ever something
that you've struggled with,
and do you have any advice?
- Oh I don't think it's a struggle,
I think it's an accomplishment.
- Cool.
(laughs)
- If you're in a place where
you're motivated by something,
do you know how many people
live 88 years of their lives
motivated by money,
and never get away from it?
Because they've never achieved the money.
- Right.
Interesting.
- Do you know how many
people are motivated by
chase of fame, for 92 years of their life
and never stop because
they never got famous?
- Right.
- This is such a fun, this
is what this is about.
That is such a subtle terminology shift.
You've been looking at it as a negative.
It's a massive positive.
(laughs)
- Absolutely, yeah.
And like I said
- Let me, I apologize, but
I want to frame it for you.
I'm secretly worried that
I'm gonna get to a place where
I'm not gonna care anything about business
and it's the love of my life.
I knew it was gonna be some run.
- Oh yeah.
- You know?
It gets weird, you know,
of course you don't get
motivated by the same things.
That's a great accomplishment, brother,
especially at this young of an age.
- Thank you.
Yeah, no like I said, in my 20's
I defined myself by the grind
and I was totally okay with that
for the rest of my life.
I remember talking, my friends were like,
where are you going with this?
How are you ever gonna make a ton of money
from graphic design,
working with these startups?
I'm just like, I love it,
I love learning new things,
discovering new people.
- It's also
- I could have done that for 50 years.
- There's also, did you
also have the feeling of
there's also an amazing
part when you feel like
you know something, and
a lot of other people
don't know it.
And then, you genuinely believe.
There's an incredible
feeling of accomplishment
when you know the unveil.
I got ragged on so heavily
for starting a YouTube show.
- Right.
- Made fun of for starting a website.
Got so much snarky comments
of starting an agency,
writing a book, speaking,
starting a sneaker.
Everything I do I get made fun of!
Even now!
It's a different level of people
that are making fun of you.
It's somebody,
it's the best!
It's my preference.
I like the boos much more than the cheers.
- That's the space I know how to navigate.
That actually leads me
into my next question,
if I may take another question.
- Go ahead.
- Yeah.
- So, I've achieved success very quickly,
and it's sort of started to,
I started to have some
interpersonal challenges.
- Makes sense.
- It's sort of interesting,
and I don't really know
how to reconcile it
so namely, people in my life,
people who are distant and close
now just treat me differently.
I can give a bunch of examples
- Give me some.
(laughs)
Just something.
- Just you know, bigger hugs.
My family's thrown me a
surprise birthday party
when I get back from New York,
which I don't want.
(laughs)
I found out and I shouldn't have,
but like, why are you doing that?
I would have never gotten a
surprise birthday party
if success wasn't attached to that.
- So, I think that's something,
the first part felt
really easy and awesome.
This one I think you have
to be thoughtful about.
Let me explain.
There's, so I think people
are a little confused.
Actually this is finally I'm excited,
I think I can articulate this well.
Ready?
I think the boos more than the cheers.
When I'm playing the game.
When I'm on the ice,
when I'm on the court.
Got it?
That is a motivator.
The second I'm off the court,
it goes the other way.
I think what you need to think about is
reconciling what drives you professionally
and not deploying that
same thing personally.
- Okay, yeah that's, definitely
- I'm watching, I can see it.
For me, I,
you're deploying cynicism
against those behaviors
for no reason.
There's no upside.
To me, if your parents were
booing you on the court,
that's a different thing
than off the court.
- Right, right.
- Got it?
- But that also leads into
just your ideas.
How do you, before, when
you're not successful,
you put out ideas and
whether they're good or bad,
even if they're good ones,
you have a 50 percent chance of someone
thinking that it's good or even thinking
that you can execute that idea.
- You know, I think
- But now that you have success
- Everybody thinks
everything I say is smart.
- Do you find that
- Here's the good news,
here's the good news.
The good news is, even though I get
motivated by the boos versus the cheers,
that's the micro.
In the macro, I can't hear anything.
- Okay.
- I'll explain.
I just don't value anybody's opinion.
And more importantly, I don't,
but I don't judge them then either.
If I don't value your opinion, friend,
well when you say it's stupid, and I win,
I don't judge you for it,
because it wasn't a factor at all,
so I'm not gonna impose on you either.
There's a level of
I think there's a sense of responsibility
with success that I'd
like to put pressure on
which is being the bigger person.
To me, it just plays out very simply,
the chess pieces.
Which is like, what's in it for you
to impose a negativity
even though you know
they're pandering to you
in a certain way.
There is,
you've won.
To me, when I win,
there is no interest in spitting on you
after I beat you.
- Right.
Right, makes sense.
- Yeah I mean,
I just don't see,
like, you won!